alors les toits le droit d'être ému
parfois on a on a on a une deuxième
lettre je crois que ces gens me je sais
pas pour qui il a écrit cette lettre
merci mais excusez moi avec micro qui
marche le mieux
moi je me fais la queue quoi tout le
côté là qui penche tout à fait d'accord
on a comme moi moi en quoi prend la
baisse des salaires on en veut pas on
comprendra que ces faits difficile toute
façon je vais vous dire la vérité c'est
surtout avec ce côté là que fait
l'émission ça nous voir mais franchement
je savais que côté là alors on y va
mon mathieu à 20h15 nous serons vacances
mais tu sais que mon amitié pour toi
n'en prendra pas de vacances pour ceux
qui suivent pas quand tu es entré dans
la famille tpn pays il ya cinq ans
j'ignorais là parce que tu prendrais
dans ma vie aujourd'hui j'en suis ravi
pas un jour sans qu'on s'appelle qu'on
se marre ou qu on se remonte le moral
bref qu'on se partage donc une petite
vie voilà je ne sais pas si tu as espère
un jour coucher avec moi mais
l'essentiel est que tu es déclaré il ya
quelque chose me coucher sur ton
testament voilà neutralisent pas faire
machine arrière j'ai demandé
l'enregistrement de ce passage la
production et mon notaire en est une
copie de façon plus professionnelle
je voulais surtout te dire ce soir que
tu est pour moi le meilleur chroniqueur
un vrai showman drôle percutant dans ses
analyses
bourré de talent est toujours sincère
d'envoi vous n'êtes pas produit
ici tout le monde t'aime et moi je suis
fier de tes mais un peu plus beaucoup
plus que les autres je t'embrasse très
mignon mignon qui n'a pas les appâts
pardon pour la bride non mais attendez
mais comment on va faire mais ce sont
des consignes et déjà
quand vous à vouziers non mais vrai
j'étais un peu tout à l'air valérie
comment vas tu sais pas pour les autres
mais moi ça commence à beaucoup de
manques et ne soit pas compte à quel
point le monde voit s'embrasser peu
qu'on peut pas surcharger humainement et
tout ça ça devient difficile à joueurs
bref personne notamment jean mi mais
c'est difficile
itunes est ému 13 c'est très beau ce
qu'il écrit lui aussi décrit très bien
des surgelés musée de tresses et c'est
très touchant et c'est vrai le juste
pour lui répondre trois secondes que
c'est vraiment une rencontre jean-louis
c'est vrai mais j'adore tout le monde
adore valérie ya plein de gens que
j'adore mes jambes me c'est autre chose
c'est mon grand frère parce qu'un grand
frère un ami
c'est un frère qu'on a choisi pour moi
ces 5èmes chroniqueur s'est du coup ces
deux clés noires